>>Alex Komoroske: Hi.
Welcome.
Thanks for coming back after lunch.
We'll get started.
I'm Alex Komoroske.
>>Matthew McNulty: And I'm Matt McNulty.
>>Alex Komoroske: And we both work on Chrome
on the Open Web Platform team.
Now, before we get really started I just want
to reiterate that this is an intermediate
level talk, so if you saw Eric's talk just
before this, before lunch, you're probably
all set.
If not, there are going to be a lot of points
where you're just scratching your head, and
what you want to do is review some of the
other specs and tutorials on some of these
emerging web standards afterwards.
>>Matthew McNulty: And all children should
leave the room as well.
[ Laughter ]
>>Alex Komoroske: So if you saw Eric's talk,
you're probably thinking to yourself, you
know, "Wow, web components sounds really cool.
Specifications are being finalized.
Browsers are starting to implement them."
But...
>>Matthew McNulty: But if you're a web developer,
you're thinking, "I probably can't use these
things.
Call me in a few years when I actually can
and when this is actually relevant to me."
>>Alex Komoroske: So the good news for you
is actually that this stuff works in all modern
browsers today.
>>Matthew McNulty: So here I have a version
of TODOMDC.
>>Alex Komoroske: And if you don't know what
TODOMDC is, it's just a reference application.
It's something that people use to write this
application again in their framework to compare
it and see how it feels compared to other
frameworks.
>>Matthew McNulty: But the interesting thing
about this one, if I inspect elements, is
it uses web components.
So you see the entire thing is wrapped up
in a TD dash app tag.
And if I go into settings, I can click show
Shadow DOM, leave, reinspect, and you'll see
now I can actually open that node and the
grayed-out document fragment is actually a
sign that you're in Shadow DOM now.
So this entire little world inside this tag
is encapsulated from the outside world.
There's a hard border at the edge.
>>Alex Komoroske: Okay.
But so that's easy because that's Chrome,
so what about something harder?
>>Matthew McNulty: All right.
In this VM which I've paused, because that
seems to be the best way to get Windows to
stay up for this period of time --
[ Laughter ]
>>Matthew McNulty: -- for purposes of this
presentation I've got it here in IE as well
in Windows 8.
>>Alex Komoroske: So it's the same code using,
again, these concepts of Shadow DOM web components
that's working in IE.
So how did we do this?
How did we make this happen?
Well, the answer is that we're impatient.
We're really excited about web components
but we didn't want to wait to use them until
they were in every modern browser.
The other important thing is we work on the
Chrome team where some of the folks who are
actively standardizing the web components
stuff in the standards bodies, and when you're
designing new web standards, it's really important
to experiment with them, especially if they're
very complex.
What you don't want is you work on a specification
for a while, you build consensus, you implement
it, you ship it, and then you use it and you
go, "Oooh, wow, that's really hard to use."
And so you want to experiment with this stuff
and feed that feedback directly back into
the standardization process before it gets
locked in.
So you want to, you know, improve these standards
and not just work around them.
So we started what was kind of a crazy experiment
to see if we could make this stuff work in
modern browsers.
We started a project a number of months ago
on Github doing everything fully in public.
We called it Toolkitchen until a few days
ago when we renamed it Polymer.
>>Matthew McNulty: We renamed it a few times,
actually.
>>Alex Komoroske: If you were working on it
closely, there were two renames in short succession.
We've already gotten some really good community
participation from folks who have found out
about it and provided feedback.
We're really happy about that.
And we've also been able to provide feedback
back into the specification process to help
identify some areas in the specs that we thought
needed to change.
>>Matthew McNulty: So we're focused on modern
browsers for a couple of reasons.
Older browsers, you just can't polyfill some
of this stuff.
And really it's -- you know, it's time for
a break.
We want to move forward.
And we don't want anyone who is using this
stuff to be left behind, kind of like the
current older browsers that don't update.
You know, you're headed for trouble if all
do you is stare in the rearview mirror.
So this approach is hard.
We didn't know it would work.
We actually didn't really know it would work
for the first six months or so, whether we
could actually get this stuff working in a
way that really emulated the future platform
in a way that we could work together and form
a coherent system.
We've been working with all the different
standards bodies and providing feedback, as
Alex said.
Yeah.
>>Alex Komoroske: But the point is actually
that it does work today and it brings you
the future and allows you to build on top
of it today.
So the way I think about this is what's actually
implemented in browsers today is like the
bedrock.
It's a solid foundation but it's kind of uneven
because different browsers have different
support for different things.
The answer to this is polyfills.
Not a new concept.
A polyfill is a JavaScript library that basically
mocks out a future standard so that you can
use it before it actually is deployed in all
modern browsers.
The goal with polyfills is to have really
high fidelity, so that way, later you don't
even need it.
>>Matthew McNulty: So perfect fidelity is
not always possible in some of these things.
Everyone always goes, "Oh, but what about"
and they're usually right.
So things like styling scoping, encapsulation
in any real significant way, are just not
possible in JavaScript but we've gotten pretty
close.
>>Alex Komoroske: So we'll go over these polyfills
very briefly.
These are each -- almost all of these are
emerging standards so we only have a chance
to say about a sentence about each one.
If you are wondering what these are, check
out the specs, check out the tutorials to
learn more about these.
>>Matthew McNulty: So mutation observers allow
for the efficient observations of DOM, so
when new nodes are added or attributes are
changed.
This one is actually already shipping in most
modern browsers.
>>Alex Komoroske: So the next one is pointer
events.
This is a specification that unifies the event
models for touch and mouse.
It allows you to write the same code and have
it run on mobile devices and desktop devices
as well.
In fact, everything we're showing you here
today works both on desktop and on mobile
devices.
>>Matthew McNulty: So Shadow DOM is a pillar
of web components.
This brings encapsulation to the platform
for the first time.
Which is really, really, really big and we'll
show that to you a little bit.
It's also incredibly complicated, especially
to grasp right away, but the big -- the big
point is it gives you the ability to encapsulate
things within a tag.
And so if you need to know more about that,
I refer you to Eric's talk that happened just
before this one, or just before lunch.
>>Alex Komoroske: The next one is custom elements.
This is another pillar of web components.
It allows you to define your own tags and
have them operate just like any other tags
in the browser.
It allows you to create these elements and
put whatever you want inside of them, even
ones of arbitrary complexity, and have them
treated just like any other tag that you're
familiar with, like the video tag or Canvas
or whatever.
>>Matthew McNulty: HTML imports.
This one was known as a few different things.
Link rel imports, web components itself briefly
for a little bit, but now it's HTML imports.
And the big thing with this one, it allows
you to package CSS, JavaScript, HTML, into
a single module and import it into your app
and it allows reusability across multiple
applications or multiple parts of your application.
>>Alex Komoroske: So this next one is MDV,
which stands for "model driven views."
This is the only one in this list that isn't
really an emerging standard yet although hopefully
one day it will be.
It's something that allows you to do data
binding directly in HTML.
And as we've been playing with all of these,
this is one that really allows us to eliminate
a lot of boilerplate code in practice.
>>Matthew McNulty: So web animations unifies
CSS and SVG animations and exposes the primitives
beneath those and allows you to create really
complex animation sequences separate from
the things you want to animate.
It's actually a really, really cool project.
It predates when we started working on toolkitchen,
now polymer.
And actually Mozilla, Google, Adobe, were
all collaborated on that polyfill and it's
included.
>>Alex Komoroske: So together, these form
a stable foundation that allows you to pretend
like you're living in the future and build
there.
So the cool thing about polyfills is that
over time as the -- as browser vendors implement
these features, the need for them goes away,
and so ultimately at some point in the future
you wouldn't even need this layer at all.
>>Matthew McNulty: So and one of the other
great things about this is we designed this
to be a la carte.
So you can use each individual -- each individual
polyfill or you can combine a couple together
or you can take the entire thing, and if you
want, actually, to take the entire platform
and minimize a gzip version of that, it's
actually only 31K.
So think about that.
That's actually the entire future of the web
platform for about the size of an icon.
>>Alex Komoroske: Most of the future of the
web platform.
So we've been talking about modern browsers.
Let me define that real quick.
This is our compatibility chart for our polyfills.
It includes Chrome, Firefox, IE, Safari, also
their mobile variants.
We call these the evergreen browsers.
These are browsers that are modern.
They support, many of them, the new standards.
They also importantly keep their users updated
by default.
So users don't have to do anything unusual
just to stay on the newest one.
So the users aren't going to live in the past
for long.
When there's a new version, they'll just come
along to the new version, which is really
important.
Okay.
So web components provides -- this foundation
layer provides a lot like a utility belt that
allows you to build apps but it's not everything
you need.
You need some higher-level stack pieces to
fit them together and really make them work
together.
>>Matthew McNulty: We realized we needed to
build a toolkit.
So this toolkit, which we call polymer, it
weaves together all of the lower level pieces
of the platform into a whole cloth for building
applications.
It's also where we express our opinion on
top of that.
>>Alex Komoroske: So this layer, unlike the
layer below it which will disappear over time,
this layer will continue to exist because
it's not part of any spec.
It's our opinion on how to use these things
productively together.
Although hopefully maybe if these kinds of
patterns become popular and other libraries
use them too, maybe this is something that
could be specified in a web standard in the
future, maybe.
>>Matthew McNulty: So we started out with
some core principles to build a new kind of
toolkit, right?
One with the future in mind.
So this is -- you know, we're leaving behind
the past.
We've got these new toys to play with.
What can we do if we actually had all of these
things and does it actually work?
>>Alex Komoroske: So these principles are
use the platform, eliminate boilerplate, and
everything is an element.
>>Matthew McNulty: So use the platform.
So this is a big change, at least for me and
others who have built JavaScript frameworks
before.
You know, for the most part, the web has been
not particularly great -- a great spot to
build Webapps.
The platform, like Alex said -- right? -- it's
rocky, it's uneven on the bottom of the.
And, you know, as a result, a lot of really,
really talented JavaScript developers have
spent their time building frameworks and building
these entire worlds and separate render trees
and doing really kind of crazy amazing things
like using iFrames to force rendering behavior
in the browser, you know, just to get around
problems -- problems on the platform.
So, you know, we were tasked very specifically,
you know, no tricks.
So if you hit a problem and, you know, something
doesn't work well, you know, we're on the
Chrome team so we're actually allowed to go
to the guy around the corner in the next cube
and say, "Hey, can you fix this?"
>>Alex Komoroske: "Let's file a bug.
Let's get that fixed."
>>Matthew McNulty: A bug, yeah.
So we wanted to use the platform, not just
the existing platform but this new platform.
We have all these new toys that we're being
given.
We wanted to see what we could do with them.
>>Alex Komoroske: The next one is to eliminate
boilerplate.
So on this team we're very, very adamant about
that, that you should only write the code
that's unique to your app and nothing more.
You shouldn't have to be recreating these
things every single time you're writing an
app.
>>Matthew McNulty: And everything is an element.
This one is really, really important but I'm
going to hammer it home about a hundred more
times so you can not pay attention to this
one.
So the idea is every single thing is a module,
right?
And you use an element.
And you build applications out of bigger and
bigger elements made -- made of more and more
elements, up to and including an actual app.
By doing this, you've got all these reasonable
little portions.
You keep the developer's context really local.
You reduce bugs.
And it makes it so that, you know, from the
perspective of a developer at any given time,
an application can be arbitrarily -- sorry,
arbitrarily simple and complex at the same
time.
So we wanted a system that weaves together
the platform to enable component-based apps.
So everything is an element and every -- and
all elements have Shadow DOM encapsulating
them.
Polymer makes building elements easier, and
from the outside -- you know, from the inside,
you're building your own in polymer.
From the outside, it's just an element.
It looks like every other DOM element.
>>Alex Komoroske: So just like every other
DOM element, the way you pass in configuration
is via attributes and the way you pass things
out of it is via element, so from the outside
perspective, it's just an element.
>>Matthew McNulty: So this is an example of
polymer JS element.
This one is a polymer panels element, so all
custom elements need to have a dash in the
name.
That's the only requirement.
It used to be an X dash.
But this allows for different vendors to provide
their own prefix to things, and namespace
to things, and it's important to note this
is not XML namespacing.
There's, you know, no collision detection
or things like that.
People just have to be on good behavior.
So in this case, it's a polymer panels app
that would provide like say a series of sliding
panels or a carousel or something like that.
So one of the first big features that we add
is declarative mapping of custom and DOM events
to methods within the element.
So in this case when a select event is fired,
the panel select handler element with that
method name -- this is not code that's executed
-- will be rerun on the actual element.
>>Alex Komoroske: So again, this makes it
easy to behave just like any other element
and pass things out via events.
>>Matthew McNulty: Yeah.
And one of the nice things we like about this
is rather than like what's currently in vogue
with add event listener and for security reasons,
we've reestablished a way of doing it in declarative.
Kind of the whole thing we're doing here -- you
know, every single thing we do, we can also
do imperatively but we like the idea of the,
you know, declarative renaissance.
So the next thing is custom attributes.
So you've got custom elements, you need custom
attributes.
This is the API that your element exposes
to the world.
And then one of the big things we add is data
binding and this is powered by MDV.
This radically reduces code complexity.
We'll -- we're going to demo this in a little
bit so we'll get into it more.
And there's a whole bunch more, but this is
the big picture, and if you combine all of
this with all the new platform bits, you end
up with something pretty awesome.
>>Alex Komoroske: So as we're using this,
this already made it much easier to build
apps but we weren't satisfied because we were
realizing that we were rebuilding the same
kind of UI widgets again and again.
And, you know, every framework that wants
to make an easy-to-build app, they should
help you build UIs as well.
We really need to build a set of really great
widgets, and so we've just begun that a few
weeks ago.
So I want to -- this is a -- this is the -- sort
of completing this diagram.
I want to take a moment to reflect really
quickly on our approach.
So a lot of other frameworks are sort of forced
to do everything in script.
They have to do very, very, very clever engineering
to replace the pot from below them because
it doesn't do the things they need.
So they end up building their own parallel
universes that don't inter-operate very well
because they've created their own worlds.
What we were trying to do is fix the platform
and actually provide feedback back to the
platform, use the emerging standards.
And we -- actually, one thing that's cool
about web components is that your interoperability
layer is just the DOM because an element is
an element, you know how to work it.
And that means that for the first time actually
it's possible for UI elements to be interoperable.
So you'll see in this diagram -- it's actually
very, very hard to see here -- there's other
boxes to the right of this, because other
UI elements could be built on top of some
of these layers or the foundation and inter-operate
with them.
And we'll show you a little bit more about
that later.
They're -- also in polymer, we've taken a
layered approach to everything.
So if you want to use our UI elements, great,
you get the whole stack.
If you just want to use a single polyfill
by itself, cool, just take that one.
Or anything in between.
So you can sort of figure out exactly how
much of this stuff you want to use.
So we've been talking a whole lot about this.
Let's -- but rather than continue to just
talk about it, let's show you how all this
stuff works.
>>Matthew McNulty: All right.
So here we have a code editor.
This is actually just the ace code editor
that we threw in a browser with some other
fancy stuff, and this is an element definition.
So if you saw this from Eric's talk, it should
be somewhat familiar.
This one is, you know, ever so slightly different
because it's a polymer element.
But the basics are still there.
So you've got an element tag.
In this case, the name attribute says it's
my dash element.
That means that's the tag we're going to create.
So whenever this element definition is around,
the tag that says "my element" will include
all of this stuff.
The template tag is the DOM that you want
to stamp out when this -- when this tag is
used.
There's actually a whole bunch of really cool
things you can do with template and iterate
and all these other things.
I'd encourage you to go look that up after
this.
And then there's the script tag which provides
the prototype for the element and various
behaviors, if you want to add.
So in this case we'll just start out really
simple and I'll add a div, "hello world."
>>Alex Komoroske: So if you can't see it -- I
know this is a big room.
Back there, if you can't see it, we can zoom
it a little bit maybe, but check it out.
All this stuff is in the repo afterwards.
We can provide the you the link.
Sorry about that.
>>Matthew McNulty: There you go.
So now for previews.
Look at that.
"Hello world."
>>Alex Komoroske: That is amazing.
Absolutely mind blowing.
[ Laughter ]
>>Matthew McNulty: But if I look inside it,
you can see here's our element definition
that we created and right next to it is an
actual instance of my element.
And inside that is Shadow DOM, so everything
is encapsulated.
And inside that, you can see our div.
>>Alex Komoroske: So if you're scratching
your head, this is the point where we remind
you this is an intermediate level talk and
if this confuses you, you should check out
-- learn more about Shadow DOM.
So in fact, to see this stuff, Shadow DOM
inspector, you actually have to check an option
to see it.
It's not available by default because it's
encapsulation.
>>Matthew McNulty: All right.
So one of the cool things is you don't actually
have to use just normal DOM elements in here.
You can have custom elements that include
other custom elements.
So in this case, I'm going to switch it to
one of our custom elements, G ratings.
And this element is cool for a few reasons.
It's very easy to type, so I can't mistype
it here.
It doesn't need any properties or attributes
by default.
And what it gives you is a bunch of stars
you can click on.
It's like a star rating thing.
Preview it, and look at that.
We've got stars.
>>Alex Komoroske: So these are just custom
elements, so if you're looking at this in
the DOM as another library, it's just an element.
You know how to work it.
Attributes in, events out.
>>Matthew McNulty: Yeah.
There it is still in my element, and then
here you can start to see Shadow DOM within
Shadow DOM and all of the markup within.
All right.
So this is pretty cool but you're like, "Oh,
you've got your own little tool."
>>Alex Komoroske: "Your own little universe
that you've built."
>>Matthew McNulty: "You're probably, you know,
cheating somehow."
So we can take the source for that document
we're creating, bring it over to JS bin, and
it's the same thing.
>>Alex Komoroske: It looks like a little bit
of boilerplate here.
There is only a couple of pieces that make
are actually crucial to make this work.
So the point is it is very easy to use this
within other contexts.
So we believe you.
By the way, this is all HTML.
But let's go a little bit faster so we don't
bore them.
>>Matthew McNulty: So it would be boring to
sit here and watch me write HTML.
So we did something to make it a little bit
faster and more interesting.
We built an element builder.
So this is just the product of the last few
weeks.
We know we are not really planning on shipping
a tool any time soon.
It allows you to build elements and bind them
together into new elements and really explore
it.
It is a nice little showcase for what we have
built so far and the technology underneath.
>>Alex Komoroske: So I am going to reiterate
that.
This is just a demo tool.
It is not an ID.
You don't need to use this to use polymer.
It is just for playing around with the stuff
and getting a feel for it.
>>Matthew McNulty: So we can rate Alex so
far.
>>Alex Komoroske: Oh, thank you.
>>Matthew McNulty: We can change it.
>>Alex Komoroske: Not so nice.
Thank you.
>>Matthew McNulty: You can see I'm changing
things in here, the number of stars selected,
the values are changing over here in the property
inspector.
This tool should be -- this kind of tool is
pretty familiar for a lot of people.
You have got a palette down the left-hand
side.
You have got a tool bar across the top and
then a property inspector down the right-hand
side.
>>Alex Komoroske: Can you flip to the code
real quick?
>>Matthew McNulty: So it is not doing anything.
It actually just changes the attribute in
the tag.
>>Alex Komoroske: Basically all this tool
is doing is just a convenience for piping
in those attributes to save you typing yourself.
It is not doing anything magic.
>>Matthew McNulty: All right.
So that's the tool to begin with.
Let's do something more interesting with MDV.
So if I pull out a few other widgets, let's
do some tabs and a menu and a caption.
This won't make any sense, but it will show
something really kind of interesting.
So I can tap around on these things.
Tap around on them independently.
If I come over to the code, you can see that
when I inserted that, I actually just inserted
a bunch of custom tags and even some normal
native DOM tags.
So the tabs takes a bunch of spans.
The menu takes a bunch of menu items.
And then the caption is actually just a div.
So one of the really cool features of this
toolkit is MDV.
MDV allows you to bind elements together and
attributes together without any actual code.
So at first I'm actually going to add a variable
to the prototype of the element here.
>>Alex Komoroske: A property you would be
able to use just like any other JavaScript
object.
>>Matthew McNulty: I can add however many
I want.
And then if I come up to any attribute within
the element, in this case "selected," I can
use this double mustache syntax which is MDV
and say --
>>Matthew McNulty: So with this G menu, the
way you specify which one is selected again
is with an attribute just like any other element.
>>Matthew McNulty: So now the tabs and the
menu in this case both have a selected attribute.
That is not at all required.
It is because they both have the concept of
what's selected in the selected index.
I come back to the code now, except for that
one.
(Chuckles.)
There we go.
Just had to clear the CSS.
You can see them connected together.
And you can actually do this right in the
tool as well.
So instead of just a caption, I can click
this little linked and put in the same thing.
And now they're all tied together.
Now, I can take this entire thing and say
"publish," clear the canvas, and now the whole
thing is itself a custom element that I can
drag off the palette and it still goes together.
And not only that, you can see the myselected
property that I added to the prototype and
even the foo one, even though it doesn't actually
do anything.
All right.
So we built a custom element and all without
doing any JavaScript actually.
>>Alex Komoroske: It is actually kind of cool,
right?
We tie these things together.
If you look in the code view for this one
as well, you will see that this is just now
a my element.
The stuff inside is sort of hidden away.
You pass the myselected that we defined in
the prototype just there as an attribute.
It wires all this stuff up together for you
so you don't have to write any script to get
this kind of behavior.
It is pretty cool.
>>Matthew McNulty: One of the other really
cool things is you can make your own custom
elements.
And one of the other uses for that is you
can wrap up existing functionality on the
Web and put it in a single tag.
And it is encapsulated from the rest of your
page, so you don't have any conflicts or system-level
dependencies that you're creating.
In which case, we'll show you one -- really
crazy one from our friends at Mozilla actually.
They built a one megabyte PDF Viewer entirely
in JavaScript.
>>Alex Komoroske: Which is crazy but awesome.
>>Matthew McNulty: We have the complete works
of Chaucer in here.
If you go to the code, you can see it is actually
just a single tag.
>>Alex Komoroske: This is kind of crazy, right?
Like, you are used to including all these
scripts and having these weird dependencies
and stuff.
You just write a few characters, one include,
write a few characters, and you have a PDF
Viewer directly in your page.
It really changes how you think about architecting
your applications.
>>Matthew McNulty: We have got other ones
in here that we just threw again in the last
few weeks.
We've got charts and things like that.
>>Alex Komoroske: These are just open source
libraries other people have built.
>>Matthew McNulty: Again, they are just all
wrapped into a single tag.
It gives you this almost module pattern that
you can use to combine things from different
vendors.
One the other neat things you can to do is
use Web animations, which we talked about
earlier.
I can actually bring out a few slightly fancier
widgets.
Let's do a clock.
So just for the demo, like, you know, tags
don't actually have to have UI, right.
Like, a script tag doesn't have anything visual
about it.
But just for this demo, we came over -- actually
we'll do flip -- and made it so these things
have a UI so we can click on them in the canvas
and do interesting things.
In this case, it is a flip animation.
And we can say, you know, let's flip the clock.
Let's do it for a second.
Now, if I come back here and click on it.
Clock flips.
>>Alex Komoroske: So behind the scenes, this
is just using Web animations.
Again, another emerging standard.
But the cool thing about thinking about animations
configured via these non-visible elements
is that you can separate the animation that
you're defining from the element itself and
just sort of point at the other one.
The elements don't have to be visual.
That's one of the cool things when everything
is an element.
>>Matthew McNulty: Yeah, so -- and one of
the other really cool things that Web animations
gives you is the ability to do really long,
really complex, intricate animations and separate
from what their target is, right?
And you can just define this and drag it out
however you want.
You reuse it and all of that.
So, in this case, we have a whole group.
So you can say let's bounce the clock this
time.
Let's flip the weather because it is not that
nice out.
And let's change up the market because I have
run out of puns.
Now if I do it, you can see they do one after
the other.
Or I can actually make it happen in parallel.
So just a little taste of what you can do
with Web animations.
Another thing we're doing is experimenting
with responsive design and building it directly
into the widgets.
I can come over here.
This is another version of the Sandbox, not
full screen, so I can actually change the
window size.
If I come in here and I start shrinking this
down, you can see it has got a toolbar across
the top of the drop-down menu.
And if I shrink it small enough, hey, it drops
down to the bottom and splits because it says,
Hey, it is phone or tablet size now and automatically
flips to be a little menu that pops up that's
more of a phone size, full-screen, full-bleed
kind of treatment.
So this is not just theoretical, but we really
just got it started -- just getting started
with this kind of element.
And, in fact, everything you see here works
on mobile, especially because we're using
pointer events.
So we're not going to put this on the camera
or anything.
But you can actually on my iPad, if I can
hold it straight -- drag stuff out on the
palette from my iPad and it just works.
>>Alex Komoroske: All this stuff is really
early.
We just started playing around with this.
We are approaching this entire project with
a very mobile-first perspective.
The ideal we're working towards is that as
a developer, you write your code once, you
define, okay, this is a menu or what have
you and then it automatically adjusts across
mobile or desktop or tablet to do the right
thing for you.
>>Matthew McNulty: All right.
So we've shown that you can drag a bunch of
elements out to make other elements.
You can bind them together arbitrarily.
You can use third-party code.
Let's actually try to put all of this together
into something fun.
So we have a YouTube widget.
We call this the "I'm feeling lucky" YouTube
widget because all it does is take the very
first query and play it.
See the little Chrome commercial.
I also call it the "I'm feeling risky" demo
widget.
>>Alex Komoroske: That's a wholesome commercial,
though, so we're okay.
>>Matthew McNulty: This is a cat video I was
using earlier in which I discovered last night
the people in the background were cursing.
I never had the sound on.
So that one went out the window.
Let's give this one a border.
>>Alex Komoroske: It is just a normal element
so you can do whatever you want.
>>Matthew McNulty: Yeah, just a normal element.
And we can actually use the speech input in
here.
And we combine the YouTube query instead of
using this plain Chrome commercial query to
the input's value.
Now if I come here and the sound system and
demo gods are in alignment, I can go "cats."
And we've got all the cats.
[ Applause ]
>>Alex Komoroske: Again, if you check out
this code, there is -- great, now we have
distracting cats on the screen.
Thank you, Matt.
[ Laughter ]
>>Alex Komoroske: If you check out that code,
it is just using that MDV syntax to plug those
things together.
The magic isn't from the Sandbox app.
The magic is from the platform and that layer
-- that sugar layer that we call polymer.
>>Matthew McNulty: We can do multiple cats
across the screen and really annoy Alex.
>>Alex Komoroske: So all this stuff is great.
But you have seen this kind of thing before.
Other frameworks have done similar kinds of
things.
What is cool about this Web components approach
where you have actual encapsulation between
them is it allows for the first time the potential
for components from of different sets to intermingle
seamlessly.
So in this world, interoperability layer is
the DOM.
And everyone knows how to use the DOM, how
to pass an attribute to receive events out.
Again, the polyfill -- the polymer library
as well is layered, so you can take just the
parts you want.
>>Matthew McNulty: So one of the cool things
we have been doing lately is our friends at
Mozilla have been building X tags in their
X tags library which is similar in concept
to the polymer widgets on top of the same
foundation layer that we showed you before.
>>Alex Komoroske: They are experimenting with
using one of our polyfills in their system
as well.
>>Matthew McNulty: Yeah.
So it took us no time at all to put them in
the palette, and I can actually drag out some
of their widgets here.
>>Alex Komoroske: So let me just emphasize
this.
These are widgets that come from a separate,
a different framework that are also built
on top of Web components.
So we can just seamlessly use them in the
same environment, in the same app.
This is kind of mind blowing, right?
This is very new.
>>Matthew McNulty: And one of the really cool
things is because this is just Web components
and these are just elements and you can bind
them together just like any other DOM elements,
we can take our toggle button and we combine
its value to the X tag switch.
Check property.
And now it will actually play together.
>>Alex Komoroske: So that's two separate libraries
playing together seamlessly.
So we think that this interoperability potential
for Web components is a really big deal.
If you think about everything as an element,
you can have small building blocks, package
them up into larger building blocks.
Before you know it, you have entire reusable
applications all in one tag.
>>Matthew McNulty: So up to and including
this entire Sandbox application, which was
built using polymer.
And as a result, we put it in the palette.
[ Laughter ]
And we can pull it out.
[ Applause ]
>>Alex Komoroske: That's cool, but we must
go deeper.
>>Matthew McNulty: All right.
Everyone get your totems ready.
We have had an inception reference.
>>Alex Komoroske: That's pretty cool.
This, in the past, would have required very
careful planning, following all the rules,
all this kind of stuff.
With Web components and polymer, you just
get this kind of encapsulation for free.
It actually -- so we've started building this
app just a few weeks ago actually as the foundation
layers got pretty solid.
We were amazed how quickly we could build
it because when you are using these concepts
to build elements and then larger elements
out of them, you are so much more productive.
It is like a whole new world.
It is really cool.
>>Matthew McNulty: So that's polymer and Sandbox
as it exists right now.
If you are adventurous and unafraid of living
on the bleeding edge -- and I would like to
emphasize "bleeding edge" -- this is a particular
version of Canary that is working right now.
We encourage you to check it out.
It is all on Github.
It is all open right now.
>>Alex Komoroske: We started this as an experiment
at the beginning to see what we could do.
But the deeper we've gone, the more and more
excited we've gotten, the more that we feel
like this is sort on the cusp of something
big with Web components.
We really believe that with Web components,
developers will be in order of magnitude more
productive building more and better apps.
So we pulled together a video that we think
-- that we hope will get you as excited about
this future we are going towards as we are.
[ Video playing.
]
[ Music ]
>>Alex Komoroske: So that's what we've got.
You can find all this stuff at our Web site,
polymer-project.org.
Learn more, provide feedback, please, please,
please.
Ask us questions.
Provide comments.
File bugs.
We'd love to get your participation.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
Now we got time for questions.
So...
>>> I'm curious, I'm looking at what you have
here.
And I'm thinking back to MooTools and Jquery
and how we got query selector all standardized
out of that.
And I'm wondering when you look at something
like Angular that has a lot of similar concepts,
how this interplays.
If you see Angular in the future as being
another sugar layer on top of something like
polymer?
Or if it Web components replaces Angular?
>>Alex Komoroske: So we aren't from the Angular
team.
There might be a few folks from that team
in the audience.
They are aware of this stuff.
They have been playing around with Web components,
providing feedback back to the standardization
process as well.
Again, one of the approaches with polymer
that's really important is the layered approach.
That means that other frameworks could take
just one polyfill or all of them or what have
you.
So I imagine that, you know, maybe that's
something that other frameworks might want
to experiment with, is building on top of
those layers, if they want.
I mean...
>>> Do you see the Web components specifications
replacing the need for a lot of the -- the
Embers and the Angulars and things that are
popular now?
>>Alex Komoroske: I think that's the wrong
way of thinking about it.
I think that the Web components provides a
lot of the utility belt.
There is always that need for sort of that
opinion to weave all that stuff together.
And I think that frameworks will always have
a place in this world because you are going
to need it to help you build your apps.
>>> Okay.
>>Alex Komoroske: It brings you far but not
all the way.
>>Matthew McNulty: I mean, It is extremely
likely that they will have to use less code
to do what they're doing, which is great for
them, great for everyone else.
But yeah.
>>Alex Komoroske: I guess we got one in the
back there.
>>> Actually, I was going to ask about Angular,
too, but I think it got answered.
So my other question would be, then, is this
something that you can -- I mean, obviously
you're using Canary, you're using a very advanced
build.
Is this something that you expect we'll need
to use only when we can tightly control the
environment in which it is running?
I came in a little late.
So backwards compatibility is my question.
>>Alex Komoroske: Just to reiterate actually,
the whole approach we're taking is building
a layer of polyfills that sort of mocks out
the future.
Matt's using Canary so we can show you real
Shadow DOM being used.
But this stuff should work across all modern
browsers, IE, Safari, Firefox, Chrome.
And over time as they implement these standards,
that sort of foundation layer will get thinner
and thinner.
>>> So when you say "modern browsers," I assume
there will be a level that we will need to
test for and then --
>>Alex Komoroske: That's correct.
One of the goals here is to really live like
we are in the future.
And if you are staring in the rearview mirror
you aren't headed for trouble.
We want to make sure we can actually assimilate
the future in a high fidelity way.
>>> When you pulled up the X code bits from
the Mozilla team, you said --
>>Alex Komoroske: X tags.
>>> Sorry?
>>> X tags.
You said it was significant because you are
pulling that in from a third-party, you know,
another vendor.
Where's the actual technical significance
there if they're kind of just doing the same
thing?
I didn't see, like, a threshold between polymer
and X tags.
>>Matthew McNulty: So, generally, if you wanted
two libraries to play together previously,
they had to either be built very specifically
to do that and not introduced system-level
dependencies or they would collide and you
would just have to get lucky, right?
The idea is with these things being encapsulated
is that you don't have those system-level
dependencies and really the world inside of
that element, which is what's using Mozilla's
code, is completely separate from the world
outside of that element.
So you can mix and match these together things
a lot easier without having to dealing with
those collisions.
>>Alex Komoroske: Before Web components, you
had to make everything in script.
So you had conventions for what it means to
be a component.
Everyone's conventions have to align for them
to be interoperable.
With Web components, people can align their
conventions on Web components, the standards,
and then that makes them interoperable much
more easily.
>>> So did you have another library you pulled
in to use those X tags?
And they just co-exist then because they are
creating DOM elements that are all happy together.
>>Alex Komoroske: Theoretically, you could
just have it as an include.
You can include a component -- in the future,
you can include a component from polymer's
UI library.
You can include a component from X tags.
You could intermingle the two or a third-party
-- or a framework that's yet to be created.
>>Matthew McNulty: It is all in that HTML
import.
>>> So you lie an aspect that's above polymer
and everything else that was significant in
that respect to X tag versus your components?
>>Alex Komoroske: Yep.
>>> Gotcha.
Thank you.
>>> So I would confirm a simple question.
This polymer also works with Chrome Packaged
Apps?
>>Matthew McNulty: Mm-hmm.
>>Alex Komoroske: Does it work right now?
>>Matthew McNulty: Right now it does not work.
The way we did the polyfill violates the SP.
>>> I see.
>>Matthew McNulty: So Chrome apps is very
specific about that.
>>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>>Matthew McNulty: But in the very near future,
once the HTML Imports feature, which is the
thing that's loading things from across domains,
is done natively, which is pretty soon, then
it will work.
>>Alex Komoroske: HTML imports is be -- just
started being implemented in Chrome.
>>> (inaudible).
(Speaker off microphone.)
>>Alex Komoroske: So you can still use -- as
(saying name) was pointing out, you can use
document.register even if you can't use some
of these other pieces like HTML imports.
>>> Thanks.
>>Alex Komoroske: We got one in the back.
>>> Yeah.
You were talking about modern browsers.
I was wondering if you could elaborate on
mobile support.
>>Matthew McNulty: So mobile, it is mobile
Safari and Chrome, Chrome for Android.
>>> And Android browser?
>>Alex Komoroske: Chrome for Android.
>>Matthew McNulty: Chrome for Android at the
moment is the only one we're testing out.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>Alex Komoroske: Again, it is very early
days.
>>> Several years ago there was actually a
similar technique that was to achieve the
similar level of encapsulation, which is XML
plus XSLT.
The essential of that is -- the picture of
that is essentially you will create a heavy
element-focused, say, Web interface instead
of having to take care of all the underlayers.
What would you compare that to Web components?
>>Alex Komoroske: I think there's been a number
of things that are similar to Web components
in the past.
None of them have really stuck around for
various reasons.
There is the things like XBL, which is still
used actually in parts of Gecko.
You've got things like the HTC stuff for Microsoft.
You have got a bunch of other things that
aims to solve all similar kinds of problems.
Web components is now like an emerging set
of specs that is --
>>Matthew McNulty: So the difference here
is that you're using the same technologies
you already use on the Web today.
>>Alex Komoroske: Yes.
>>Matthew McNulty: You are using HTML, CSS
and JavaScript.
There is actually nothing new here, whereas
XSLT, I did a whole framework in XSLT years
ago.
And that was -- to debug that was one of the
more insane things I have ever done in my
life.
>>> Great, thank you.
>>Alex Komoroske: We're actually out of time,
I believe.
If you have more questions, you can come find
us up here after the talk.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]